Our brothers and sisters
are in desperate need
of assistance to serve
the people.
You are the help that's coming.
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: The Navajo Nation
is the largest tribe
in the United States.
Twenty-seven thousand
square miles
that we have to patrol.
An increase in criminal
activity has come upon us.
Come out!
SPEAKER 2: To offer
the basic police services,
we would need 500 officers.
We have 180.
SPEAKER 3: Quite frankly,
our lives are at stake.
SPEAKER 4: Class 57,
what makes you different
from any other officer in
this country,
is you are Navajos.
SPEAKER 5: In the Navajo Nation,
everyone knows each other.
I am worried about
my dad's side finding out.
They hate cops.
SPEAKER 6: I'm scared for her,
but I know
she can handle herself.
SPEAKER 7: They're leaving
left and right,
and that's kind of got
me worried.
If you think you can handle it,
don't quit.
SPEAKER 8: I think it's dire.
Some people aren't prepared
mentally, emotionally, to deal
with it in the long run.
-You're okay. Control.
-(MUMBLING)
SPEAKER 9: I'm willing to put
my life at risk.
I'm pretty scared, though.
I've tried to tell myself,
keep pushing forward.
OFFICER: Stay where you are!
It's been a rough couple years.
We're ready to move forward.
SPEAKER 10: The success of
the Navajo police academy
could break or make the nation.
OFFICER 2:
Navajo police!